[Music]
every time i go out shopping with teddy
i end up with another bad influence it's
very bad interesting i'm buying it
right here that's how her he is oh sorry
howard
never mind you got the aviation baby
what should you do
[Music]
mr wonderful here now you know i love
watches but not all watches have to cost
a hundred thousand dollars what i'm
really concerned about is entry-level
value great brands can give you great
value if you know where to shop and
where to look
now there's nobody better at this than
teddy balzar he's right here with me
we're in longine boutique in adventura
near miami beach florida why because
this brand represents some of the best
value in horology ever it's not as well
known as some other brands in north
america but you should know this is the
number one brand in asia there are
millions of people who buy these pieces
and i've asked teddy to dig in
and pull from the collection some of the
very best pieces at great entry level
prices now teddy is very good at this
we've done this before together and it's
been very well received the reason i
care is i want you if you have that
little inkling to start collecting
watches to start here
i don't want you to go into debt to buy
a watch i want you to find something you
love on your wrist that you can afford
now
and build on
and this is the brand to do it with the
value here is insane and some of the
dials are incredible and you know i love
dials and red bands so let's go to work
teddy what have you picked out for me
here so again just to add on top of i
mean this company does a billion dollars
a year in revenue so to call them
underrated is kind of crazy but you
could still say it because here in the
united states i just don't think people
understand the value that's taking place
from the watchmaking perspective and
just where it sits so how i kind of laid
this out
starting over here now this is i would
say the entry door to long gene and they
have i would say two angles that they
approach as a brand
some of the like the higher end stuff i
would say is kind of that gateway into
luxury and then you have this which is
for a thousand or so bucks maybe some of
the best swiss watches you're gonna find
so these are let's go there let's start
right down here at sort of that sub two
thousand dollar price so starting around
twelve hundred bucks yup you can get
into a watch called the conquest now i
call these watches everyday watches this
isn't a universal term but it's just
something that i think you could just
take put it on your wrist and be good
and pretty much every scenario
70 hour power reserve 300 meters of
water resistance which pretty nuts i
mean this is a non-dive watch it has a
bit more of a kind of distinct crown is
the dial size on that this one is 43 but
these are that's the other reason why i
like these they're available in multiple
sizes 39 41 43 this one's in 41 right
here
but for 1200 bucks finishing salad will
never look out of place
now this steel with a blue dial is so on
trend right now people are loving blue
dials and this style has a lot of
different attributes the light plays
with it beautifully i love it on steel i
mean these sports watches have rocketed
to the top of desire for collectors and
for just people are looking for
something new and exciting i like it one
thing to add about long gene and their
movements i think this is a huge i think
proposition for them is they have
exclusive movements provided by etta i
mean their swatch group brand but these
are movements that are not just put in
any watch this isn't just off the shelf
at a 28.92 yeah these are movements that
are made for long gene they have their
own beat rate operating at a 3.5 hertz
beat rate so it's all just completely
it's a very accurate watch it's you know
it's an accurate watch these i mean a
lot of the different so that's an l88
caliber so those extended power reserve
uh they have chronometer certifications
which we'll look at for some of these
it's a clean look it really is it's
striking and clean so that's now here
when you go into this black dial you've
got wonderful contrast yes really
wonderful contrast that really pops and
the black
has a different i mean see this is more
sunburst with the blue that's kind of
glossier with the effect yeah when is
that going to look out of place though
never i mean it's a great sports piece
there's no question about it 125 bucks
too honestly i mean that's swiss made
yeah it's hard to beat i mean look if
you're if you're looking for something
to get into this is it i mean you know
i'm trying to make a decision out of
these three before we go there what
about this so that is the hydro conquest
it's kind of the coolest well-known
brand within the long jeans sure
absolutely but yeah what i think many
people think of when they are imagining
longing it's more the heritage pieces
and that's why i wanted to start here
because these are more contemporary in
their approach but they look great
essentially taking the same type of just
architecture with this and again not to
play with words but if you're looking at
this watch from across the room i'm
thinking submariner
ceramic bezel yeah i mean it's popping
with that glossy picture it's a what's
the price on it 1600 bucks all right
there you have it i mean that is you
know if you if you really want the
classic dive sports look you can't go
wrong with this and a ceramic bezel
that's just tremendous value i mean
that's the bottom line now let me let me
choose a favorite here which i love to
do and i'm really having a hard time
because i really like all three of these
but if you just
approach them and i always like the eye
candy appeal like i know what you're
going to pick i already know you know
it's this
i was wrong there you have it
like i just think this thing
you would have thought it would be blue
i i just i just think this piece is so
striking
i mean
i don't know it just
you never know what's going to happen
with teddy right
never know this is number one
this is number two
and this is number three although
they're all great pieces but somebody's
got to do the hard work and that's me
should we just move tray by tray is that
what i think that's what we should do
okay so what have you got here these
you're moving up the feeding chain on
price a bit here right yes yes so now
we're starting to get above two thousand
dollars for their watches this is where
i start to think about and definitely
will extend over here as well that entry
door to luxury these are i would say
luxury product at the end of the day for
some of these and i'll give reason to
that now first this is one of my
favorite watches that this brand makes
it's kind of that classic sector down
from the 1930s and 40s so many brands
made i mean every brand made kind of
their sector dial but longing with their
heritage i mean ronson's 1830 they have
the street cred to do they do i mean
there's a lot of brands that are just
going to go ahead hey i'm going to put
this out because it's popular right now
this brand is never guilty of that
because they have an archive that's as
expansive as anybody it is very clean
very striking yeah that's really nice i
got to put this piece on it's it's
almost um that bracelet's fantastic the
bracelet is fantastic but it's it's um
it's a it's a dress piece
so that's kind of why i like it now what
is a modern dress watch you know like
think about what that is and now there's
a lot of that classic elegance maybe it
almost seems forced sometimes there's
like that traditional classicism oh but
i mean look at that how it just drapes
with the bracelet yeah that is i mean
that really pops with the suit right
it looks like i look spectacular with
this on it's ridiculous somebody's gotta
watch them you might walk out with that
wow i mean that really looks
you know i gotta tell you it has it has
eye candy appeal
on the tray but when you put it on wow
the bracelet takes it to another level
yeah i think that's really something
else gorgeous piece beautiful wow okay
2100 bucks it's going to be 2300 bucks
for the bracelets yeah all right what
else do we got so this is more of an
aviation theme similar price range this
is called their spirit collection so
this is available in stainless steel
multiple sizes also in titanium now is
that titanium this is stainless steel
here so with the date now what do you
recommend between steel and titanium if
you can up you're going to pay more for
titanium you're going to get more
titanium and you're going to have the
wow appeal of titanium well with
titanium i think it kind of matters on
the application so if i'm going for a
dive watch i care more about that
because you're usually dealing with
larger presence maybe a chronograph for
example which we'll talk about a little
bit later it has more muted tones too
like on this you see like you know has
you know the chamfering on the side and
you know
just kind of the polish elements
i have many titanium pieces many steel
and they both have merit this has much
more flash and zing to it in with light
and and this dial is also i mean login
makes some amazing bracelets look at
that that is just beautiful and these
integrations are perfect you know it's
that's lovely too chronometer certified
2100 bucks i mean yeah i mean even look
at the like the brush finishing on the
side of the case i mean just it's
gorgeous it's a well finished watch
so that's where that dial is bluish
black
i see hints of green in it too
what do you think i think your eyes are
messing with you really i think it's
just black just black well i'm trying to
i'm trying to add a little sex appeal
right there there you have it
it's very nice look that is that is also
very it's just down to business right
it's aviation style it's not
forcing anything that it's not
very clean very good very good look more
of a sport vibe to it sure
and you get that you get you know
extended water resistance and that's
that's an everyday watch too i think if
you have a little bit more money to
spend you want to go next year from over
here i think it's a little more um into
more fashion-esque in some ways you know
it's true
that's good okay now this piece there's
a lot of complications around here
i don't like to be overly emphatic right
but
i'm hard-pressed to think of another
watch that's more complicated for the
money and what you can get from a value
perspective if you like complications
yeah and how many does this have well
it's a calendar and a chronograph so a
calendar chronograph let's let's change
the
sphere of how we use this in other
brands these pieces go for a hundred
thousand dollars i just covered a patek
5970 on the channel yeah they don't make
that anymore you use a lamonia based
caliber and they use a professional
mechanism this isn't not a perpetual but
that's a difference but still you're
talking 160 to 170 thousand dollars
right that watch 3 325 wow
okay
that's amazing
so that is tremendous value because
you're right you can't get anywhere near
this
that a chronograph for one
i'd say one of the most over
looked ideas in watchmaking is how
difficult it is to make
a proper chronograph also with the
thickness i mean look at that you have a
perpetual or you have an annual calendar
how large is style on this it's very
that's i believe 41 on this because it's
very friendly on the wrist yeah pretty
pretty compact as well the bracelet does
just kind of drape over the wrist
straight down i mean this is a very
sophisticated look when you get
something like this with all these
complications people are going to glaze
down at your wrist and say wow what is
that because there's a lot going on here
yet it's a beautiful dial this is
probably the best value on this tray
right now
i i think so yeah i think so yeah i mean
it's it's really really beautiful now
having said that i got to make a choice
here um and i'm going to write a ranking
okay i like this we're going to trade by
trade now i know i'm going to rank this
i i was
this was interesting to me until i put
it on my wrist and it became number one
this is one
hell of a watch i mean it is just this
is a spectacular piece and i'll tell you
why it's it's a very unique when you're
buying watches if this is your first
watch you want a striking dial you buy
for dial that's what you do something
that and this is this is elegant it's
sophisticated it's beautiful and it's
unique and it's an amazing price that'd
be my choice as well yeah despite yeah
good value here it's where did the is
taking you going i'm going here for
number two because it's just just
tremendous value it's ridiculous value
it's fantastic value you can't beat it
and it's a beautiful striking dial it
really pops beautiful contrast easy to
read the time even though it's loaded
with complications i love complications
too so that's number two
and number three but there's nothing
wrong with this we can fight about
whether it's a green or black dial but
you know i i like it let's get some
close-ups on this one we got to put this
direct you know but it's it's sort of
it's nice but it's number three i i just
i can't talk enough about this piece i
mean this is really off it's also
available in silver too what would the
price be on that same it's a little bit
cheaper because not
on the bracelet if you go for the
conventional strap it's 2100 bucks
anyways you know i i don't get
emotionally involved too often but this
piece is unbelievable i mean just i'm
glad you like that i'm actually
surprised i thought you were going to
think that was too just no it's
traditional not going to be free it
shows you how broad the the brand is it
can give you all these different looks
it's fantastic now let's go a little
more upscale here right let's do it yeah
well i think we're kind of in the same
range but we're up above two thousand
dollars into you know the five thousand
dollar range so this is the watch i just
saw today i didn't even me too i've
never seen that piece so apparently it's
uh honoring uh lindenburg and the
transatlantic flight right here that's
howard hughes oh sorry howard
never mind you get the aviation
you know he kind of looks like him what
the hell i mean he's got the leather hat
you know the leather hat the kind of the
hair jumping out of the cockpit what can
you do so i mean this is basically used
for navigating on these transatlantic
flights so
this is you're supposed to put this on a
map
yes it's like 180 degree view you put
this on a map and it'll help you with
navigation which is kind of a concept
it's got the hatchback case back too so
you can see the movement now the
challenge for me is look at the size of
the of the dial here it's broad you know
and i'm not against this i do wear
pieces this large i mean you're really
making a statement you're you're wearing
a wall clock on your wrist but this is a
beautiful dial it's got all the classic
elements to it you know roman numerals i
mean just beautiful
a lot going on here
and this back is very interesting i
don't know if i have the nails for it
but there's a little little
and you can open the back right
there you got the nails there yeah look
at that isn't that cool it's got a this
is the elements of a pocket watch from
way back and a description of the piece
inside inscribed beautiful
beautiful what's the price on this teddy
i think it's right on five
five thousand dollars
amazing
now if you you know the funny thing is
i've been seeing women wear dials this
size now oversized like crazy i think
it's a good look i like it you know i
like it my wife has been stealing my
watches and my big ones and just getting
the bands reduced in size and then
losing the links and saying oh my
goodness oh sorry kevin yeah sorry
all right what else you have here
now the next two are ones that i thought
were going to be these are slam dunks
these are kevin o'leary watches i've
ever seen them so the first one here
this is the avigation big eye so
maybe the best value for a chronograph
from a swiss watch making perspective
and i say that for two reasons one is
again the idea of
longing having access to these movements
this is a column wheel chronograph
movement that you're getting for just
north of three thousand dollars which is
remarkable it's so well finished grade
five titanium and they call this
petroleum blue with that dial and i
thought if i had to pick one of these
dials i'm like kevin's going to go for
this yeah this is the one you're right
but it's not just the blue i mean the
blue is spectacular it's so that
gradient just yeah in fact but working
with the you know this this titanium in
a subtle way but also look at the design
of that dial it's just so they call it
the big eye and the reason they call it
the big eye is because of that sub
register at the three o'clock so that's
going to be uh
easy indication and aviation type
environment to track that yeah
that is really that's a really i mean
it's a gorgeous piece and you can get
you know the great thing about this is a
sports piece but very elegant too and
blue is so on trend these days it's just
blue is just not stopping what do you
think about the weight too like just
grab me one of the stainless steel
pieces and grab that that's a
chronograph and they just pick something
up yeah big difference
that's i love the lightness of it also
it's not over it's not oversized yet
it's got a lot going on 41 yeah very
wearable
pricing what's the price again 32
25. that's incredible value incredible
value
gorgeous and you're right i like the
blue
that's you know
you th the the the hands on this have
great contrast against the blue which is
usually an issue when you're talking
about kind of that faux lume effect but
it works because you're gonna just look
glance over and you'll definitely get it
and that's a problem in a lot of pieces
that's gorgeous what do we have here so
if you have to think about the
poster child of the heritage collection
for longine it's probably this family
watch this is the legend diver so this
is known as a compressor case uh so back
in like the 1960s there's a company
called epsa they make all these cases
for all these brands one of them was
long gene and the two things around it
that made it was special was how it was
able to achieve its water resistance
rating so the compressor style it's
almost like a sandwich and as you go
down to greater depths it compresses the
case so it's using the
actual pressure of being underwater as a
benefit to be more water resistant to
have a seal so that's the one that's
just rated down to this is 300 meters
whoa
and the other thing is i'm not down to
300 very often people are ridiculous
when they say like 100 meters isn't
enough it's nonsense no one's going to
use this for full capacity but the other
thing that's cool about it it has the
tool two crowns yeah and one's going to
be for rotating that bezel at the two
o'clock point of that was when you're
dealing with time-lapse bezels back in
the day before diving computers this is
a matter of life or death you don't even
know how long your dives are this is
really interesting in terms of how this
is mounted it's it's it's got a very
flat
um
yeah
it's thin yeah it is faceted case
listen very interesting dial actually
again with good contrast so you can see
this it probably has a good luminosity
under water
yes and what that one is going for is
kind of that tropical dial so if you've
ever seen those really aged dive watches
that have just been in the sun like hell
and they've just been kind of aged that
way that's what that one's going for
which i think they did a nice job it
doesn't look forced in price again teddy
2300
incredible
it it's got a great sports vibe to it
but very clean i mean they've
this brand has done a really good job
with its styles i mean obviously they've
got the history to know what works but
some of these particularly the newer
pieces are stunning and i i can honestly
i think you have definitive watch of
this style here for the price definitive
watched out for the price i mean
definitive here i mean it's just it's
tough but let's rank these top 10 i like
so you know it's obvious this has to be
number one and there's this style is
just i thought that was going to be your
number one yeah it's 10 out of 10 um in
terms of just
a really well designed dial
that's uh that really pops i mean it's
got a beautiful view so that's number
one
now this is a little eclectic i mean
this is a pocket watch on a strap in
some ways but with the heritage and the
mapping and all that i mean it's you
know it's got a really good story and i
love dials with stories i mean you could
talk about this for half an hour sure i
mean you know lindbergh gets off the
plane says i need to redesign a watch
that works with my map when i'm flying i
mean that's basically what happened here
uh it's it's gorgeous it's a beautiful
piece the only thing that you would say
negative if you're not into really large
format this isn't going to work for you
but large format
you know has become very accepted and
and i said earlier for women's fashion
as well and what's the intended purpose
right if you're talking about an
aviation watch you need to be able to
see it you need it
it makes sense again they've done an
amazing job on the contrast you can just
uh you know the way you test contrast is
you glass to watch the side of the of
your site and if you could immediately
read the time they've done a fantastic
job of contrast and certainly that's the
case here and lastly this tropical thing
you talked about i like it a lot you
know it's not as much for me because i
prefer if you're going to go red go red
like this is sort of i need to get some
different dial colors for you yeah i
mean you know this is sort of toffee red
dish kind of thing but i don't i don't
mind it um it's actually a beautiful
case there's no question
steel
just well polished beautiful they have
that in bronze too which is pretty
interesting that is interesting bronze
with that same dial they have a variety
of different dials okay because that
would be a nice marriage and that's uh
it's it's a great piece but you know
it's going to be number one
you can't go wrong with that
number two um
i mean you know the history of this
piece and it's
i don't know i'm warming up to it even
as i hold it it's sort of
maybe you know could it get to number
one and then number three i mean you
know i like it but you know can't love
everything you have a winner on the
entire table what's the number teddy i
gotta do it yeah
it's tough i'd pick mine if you pick
yours i will pick mine okay
um
yeah i'm gonna go with this that wasn't
gonna be my pick too yeah i mean this
just
for the value and how elegant that is
this just
i do a review every single year about my
just
top watches of the year and i do stuff
that's just more like by category but
then i do my own personal favorites like
regardless of price whatever i liked
two years in a row last year was the
silver
again that's going to be on the list
with the black yeah and this and the
silver version has the same bracelet and
silver as well i don't believe it's
actually available in the bracelet but
um it is available on the strap i have
not seen it on the bracelet yeah but you
can get silver this is steel yes
i mean wow
it's just
it's a stunner winner winner winner
and you just know when you put on your
wrist it just explodes to the upside i
mean this thing just look at that
anyways teddy it's been great
you've always bring so much knowledge
particularly in the most important area
of entry level pieces because if you're
going to get into watch collecting i
never want you ever
to spend money you don't have
it's a disease it's very horrible and i
have it but luckily i make a ton of
money so that's okay but this
is the way to go this is the way to
start and i think it's you've done a
masterful job here and you've really got
breadth to the line and so just
scratching the surface yeah i think jean
thank you very much this has been
absolutely amazing
you know teddy i got to tell you there's
something for everybody in this
collection that's right and in watches
until next time mr wonderful bye-bye
teddy thank you so much always a
pleasure take care everybody
i want it loose though because it's got
a it's got a bracelet type thing on it i
mean i'm going to wear this thing out
today i like it just love it
looks great with the attire today too
i'm buying it
it happens to me every time it happens
to me every time i go shopping with
teddy i end up with another bad
influence it's very bad influence this
is going to be
in my collection
today and i'm going to make sure they
make me a red band so i can wear it on
shark tank as well talk about a dress
piece like wow what a dial
i got on it that's what happens
it's all about the dial it's always
about the die when you get something
unique i don't have anything like this
in my collection that's why i'm buying
it i'm adding dial
breath diversity stunning beautiful